tonight we are getting an inside look at
a temporary medical clinic spearheaded
by some of the best
medical professionals in the valley
southwest medical teaming up with
several groups on a mission but the
location
is not in nevada it's in the dominican
republic
christian gasidas has the story
for seven days this temporary clinic in
the dominican republic
was able to provide medical attention to
hundreds of locals
living in poverty each one carefully
examined
by las vegas professionals like dr
hilary schroeder so we saw
our typical high blood pressure diabetic
patients heart failure patients
leg swelling patients common flu-like
symptoms with
cough and cold she was one of several
local medical staff that traveled to the
caribbean to offer her service
free of charge the partnership i should
say between optum and one world surgery
started
a few years ago but because of covid
was delayed and so we were the first
group volunteer accommodations are
located on the property of project
partner nuestros pequenos hermanos
a children's home 45 minutes outside
santo domingo
patients are paired up with local
medical staff for any follow-ups
a surgical facility under the same
program operates in honduras
every day we we would load up what we
called the
safari truck with thousands of pounds of
medical equipment
dividers electronic equipment and
everything that you would need to set up
a field clinic
jeff patina's role is non-clinical but
crucial to the effort
his ability alone to speak spanish was a
major asset to the team
i personally received far far more from
this trip in
in appreciating what we really have and
even with all the the trials and
tribulations that we have across the
united states
they pale in comparison to these
individuals in
the bates outside of santo domingo
christian casadas 8 news now well you
realize how many medical professionals
got in for the most virtuous of reasons
just to help others all over the world
really they really needed them